a new study highlights the potential  benefits for pregnant women to get the  coronavirus vaccine  researchers over at massachusetts  general hospital studied 131 mothers who  were recently vaccinated  and they found both the moderna and the  pfizer vaccine were highly effective in  producing antibodies in pregnant women  and breastfeeding women pregnant women  can know that not only are they  getting a good antibody response for  themselves to protect themselves against  covid  but also their potentially conferring  benefit to their baby  and we know that antibodies in breast  milk do help prevent  protect babies from respiratory  infections  pregnant women are at higher risk for  developing severe complications from  covid19  health experts say getting the vaccine  it is a personal decision and expected  mothers should speak with their doctor  before making a decision